[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'occasion de l'année nouvelle le
président de la République s'est adressé
à la nation
française à chacune de vous français à
chacun de vous
j'adresse du fond de mon cœur
mes meilleurs vœux de nouvel an
et puis en notre nom à tous je forme
pour la France le souhait immémorial que
l'année lui soit heureuse travailler
et rester unis
voilà
quels sont quoi qu'il arrive
les meilleurs de nos garanties
l'an dernier pour notre bien nous avons
su nous les assurer
l'an prochain
qu'il en soit de même
[Musique]
le temps passe mais l'homme montre une
continuité rassurante dans ses idées
fixes
1962 ville et sauteurs de tonneaux
américains s'acharnaient à sauter leur
tonneau les femmes de Nola continuaient
à apporter leur pierre à un mystérieux
édifice et en Hollande les sauteurs de
canaux pour suivre leur noble exercices
bref 1962 fut une année comme les autres
élus son festival de Cannes avec Sofia
et son moins de vacances en famille on
ne manqua pas de prodiguer les
encouragements habituels pour
l'amélioration de la race humaine
ce qui nous value des records à lui seul
j'assie un bâti 2 ceux du 3000 et du
un français Charles Bozon enleva au
championnat du monde de ski le slalom
spécial
on ne compte pas d'années sans
catastrophe un accident ferroviaire
phythe au Japon 165 morts le séisme qui
secoue la terre d'Iran provoqua le plus
lourd bilan de l'année 20.000 morts
quant à la Catalogne un déluge d'eau la
transforma par deux fois en paysage de
cauchemar
50 et quelques millions de terriens ont
par ailleurs disparu dans l'année
Marilyn Monroe en pleine gloire madame
Éléonore Roosevelt l'épouse d'un des
plus grands présidents des États-Unis en
France René Coty dernier président de la
4e République
[Musique]
pink qui avait régné 58 ans sur la
Hollande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'immortalité ne s'est portée une fois
de plus qu'à l'Académie française ou
avec René Clair le cinéma entra de plein
droit est-ce à dire que 1962 n'offrit
pas quelques différences on a envie se
manifester dans le couvre-chef qui prit
une importance certaine
[Musique]
l'homme le porta avec un autre souci de
raffine et le scooteriste fut obligé de
coiffer le casque ce dont il n'est qu'à
se louer
quant aux nouveaux fantassins américains
il a estimé le port du casque
indispensable
[Applaudissements]
envie encore des fusées récalcitrantes
mais on sentit bien lorsque la fusée
Centaure fut détruite en vol que l'Homo
americanus aurait le dernier mot
[Musique]
red Ader le pompier du pétrole n'a-t-il
pas réussi à souffler comme on souffle
une bougie l'immense flamme de 300
mètres qui brûlait agacé Queen
le twist enfin qui continua de triompher
dans l'année a dû céder des pistes au
tabouret et autres bossa nova
[Musique]
on lui vit bien lorsque des milliers de
mains bretonnes se tendirent vers
Louison Bobet qui abandonnait le site
lis on le vit bien quand pour la
première fois depuis 50 ans le 15 de
France vaincu chez lui le 15 britannique
Jeanne d'Arc était une nouvelle fois
vengée et puis le monde avait tremblé
sur ses bases lorsque les avions
américains survolant Cuba il y avait
repéré des bases de lancement soviétique
pendant 8 jours 3 milliards d'être ont
été suspendus aux lèvres de trois hommes
Kennedy décidé
fidèle Castro prenons volontiers une
politique intraitable
[Musique]
chauffe enfin qui accepta le retour des
fusées
moyenne en quoi on ne parle pas trop de
Berlin
toujours en place le mur à voix de temps
à autre des faiblesses
[Musique]
les autorités de l'Est s'employèrent
alors à les combler largement
Adolf Eichmann bourreau de 6 millions de
Juifs fut livré à la potence on trouve à
la justice bien douce
à Liège par contre on applaudit au
verdict bien qu'il est acquitter Suzanne
et Jean vanne depuis des milliers de
familles avaient partagé leurs drames
[Musique]
Londres connu des dimanches agités du
fait de ce reçoit de Mosley chef du
parti fasciste anglais on s'explique à
ferme à Trafalgar Square à Bruxelles
aussi du reste mais pour des raisons
toutes différentes dans le but
d'affirmer sa position en matière
linguistique le Comité d'action flamand
organisa une marche sur la capitale
pour l'Inde envahi par les troupes
chinoises 1962 a été une année
déchirante le président des routes du
abandonné un pacifisme dont il s'était
fait une règle d'or
quant à Monsieur Mac Millan il lui forte
affaire pour convaincre le commonwell de
la nécessité pour Londres d'entrer dans
le marché comme
l'Europe entre temps avait enregistré un
événement sans précédent sanctionné par
le voyage triomphale du général de
Gaulle en Allemagne la réconciliation
franco-allemande est apparue comme le
fait capital de la vie européenne
[Applaudissements]
Aaron Jean 23 dont la santé a beaucoup
inquiété le monde catalytique a ouvert
et clos la première session du concile
ecuménique Vatican 2 réuni au sommet
l'église est placée devant les grands
problèmes de notre siècle
[Musique]
1962 ce fut aussi ce fut d'abord pour la
France la fin de la guerre d'Algérie à
Évian les accords que Monsieur Jobs
signait avec Belkacem crime mirfa un
drame douloureux qui avait duré 7 ans le
retour à la première paix totale depuis
1939 n'alla pas cependant sans violence
à Paris on compta jusqu'à 17 plasticages
dû à l'os dans une journée
au Petit Clamart le général de Gaulle
fut une seconde fois la cible
d'adversaires déterminée qui décharèrent
leurs armes sur sa voiture
[Musique]
Alger on enregistra des destructions
spectaculaires et l'on se demanda si
l'os allait-il mené jusqu'au bout ce
qu'on appelait la politique de la terre
brûlée
ce ne fut que d'ultime soubresaut et le
oui des Français à la paix aboutit à la
naissance de l'État algérien indépendant
à peine née l'Algérie indépendante avait
cependant souffert d'une crise de
personnes qui devait finir au bénéfice
de l'ancien prisonnier de l'île d'Aix
Ben Bella
[Applaudissements]
mais toute cette suite d'événements
avais-tu pour conséquence le départ de
600 000 Européens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en décidant de lire désormais le
président de la République au suffrage
universel et en envoyant à la chambre
une majorité de gouvernement la France
s'insta allait dans une stabilité
rarement connue
le monde lever les yeux vers le cosmos
dans ce domaine l'Amérique a pris sa
revanche en faisant faire un Américain
trois tours de la terre l'homme de la
revanche sa plat Glenn
[Musique]
après lui Carpenter effectua à son tour
ces trois circonvolutions réglementaires
l'exercice semblait devenir enfant
les Soviétiques le compliquèrent en
envoyant successivement pour qu'il vogue
de concerts deux de leurs astronautes et
Nicolas yef et Popovic s'acquitter
ponctuellement de leur mission
on en est ainsi arrivé au point confite
à peine attention à la réussite du vol
du troisième américain Skira comme dire
les techniciens c'était de la routine
mais revenons sur terre ou tout de même
jusqu'à nouvel ordre nous sommes
condamnés à vie en France la
construction de l'usine de la Rance nous
a promis l'utilisation prochaine de
l'énergie des marées avec le commandant
wow le bathyscaf a fait un pas plus vers
l'observation des profondeurs marines en
descendant à 9208 mètres dernier
peut-être des transatlantiques le France
a reçu le salut traditionnel de New York
il n'y a plus de Mont Blanc le tunnel
routier a été percé et Monsieur Pompidou
s'y est rencontré avec Monsieur Fanfani
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois les émissions de
la télévision traversée l'océan le petit
village breton de ploemeur-bodou où a
été installé le Rado mais son oreille
géante y a gagné une célébrité mondiale
mais la mondovision surtout a marqué une
date celle du début de l'utilisation des
satellites pour notre usage direct
c'est dire que les savants ont désormais
d'autres ambitions que de faire le tour
de la terre toujours en France les
radiotélescopes sans attendre les
prochains voyages sur la lune ou mars ou
Vénus ont commencé à interroger les
galaxies à des milliards
d'années-lumière
1962 peut donc encore nous faire rêver
[Musique]
les joueurs du Stade de Reims maillot à
manches blanches ont éprouvé une
désagréable surprise à Monaco
contrairement à l'habitude il pleuvait
en effet à torrent dans la principauté
au début du match contre les Monégasques
mais ce n'était pas là la seule surprise
enregistrée par les Rémois 8 minutes de
jeu à peine ils encaissent un premier
bus signé douce
mais Reims réagit très rapidement qu'à
elle belle égalise peu de temps après
[Applaudissements]
et les rénois vont même prendre le large
un très joli une deux piant Tony akesby
un tir de voler comme on envoie plus
souvent en France deux un
après ce petit festival Rémois les
Monégasques veulent prouver que aussi
ils savent jouer au football un très
long centre de costume numéro 9 une
reprise de Hidalgo Monaco égalise
Colonna le gardien de bure et moi il est
vrai n'est pas dans un bon jour en tout
cas c'est égalisation remet Monaco en
selle et Colona va commettre une
nouvelle erreur les Monégasques jouent
bien il ne pardonne pas les erreurs
trois à deux pour menacer
[Applaudissements]
en seconde mi-temps race ne va pas avoir
beaucoup plus de chance l'équipe
tourneront lui manque cependant le tout
petit quelque chose qui devrait lui
permettre de forcer le destin c'est au
contraire Monaco qui flotte avec la
chance 4 à 2
et pour prouver qu'ils n'ont pas
seulement la chance avec eux les
Monégasques sont bien décidés à faire
bonne mesure score final 5 à 2 pour
Monaco c'est juste mais un peu sévère
pour Reims
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Paris Monseigneur Bertoli a présenté
au nom des 83 chefs de missions les vœux
du corps diplomatique au président de la
République française
une réception parmi les nombreuses
autres qui se sont succédées dix heures
durant au palais présidentiel
[Musique]
à Londres la nouvelle année sortie de
l'oeuf a déclenché les farandoles de
l'alberto
[Musique]
ce fut bien pi à Trafalgar Square ou
sous la neige les fontaines ont été
prises d'assaut par les noctambules en
mal de bain de minuit ou de 5 heures du
matin
les Londoniens ont bien fait mentir la
réputation de réserves qui s'attache au
tempérament britanniques
c'est une habitude la Joconde vient
encore de faire parler d'elle
monsieur eking un antiquaire de Nice a
conduit les journalistes aux machins
Chanteloup pour leur montrer le tableau
qu'il estimait être le vrai portrait
peint par Léonard de Vinci
ce qui revenait à dire que l'Amérique
admirait un faux ni plus ni moins
[Musique]
des preuves monsieur eking en avait une
définitive l’œil de la Joconde du Louvre
et mou affirmait-il
puis comparer l'oeil de Saint Joconde
mais l'expert italienne économie est
formelle la vraie Joconde est à
Washington on peut dire qu'il a évité le
pire entre la France et les États-Unis
d'Amérique
[Musique]
les jeunes vont de plus en plus vite et
ceci n'est pas un compte de fait devenir
à 18 ans une vedette du disque une
vedette plus vendue que la Callas alors
qu'il y a six mois elle n'était encore
qu'une timide étudiante en langue
allemande telle est l'aventure vécue par
Françoise Hardy elle rêvait bien sûr des
lauriers d'Elvis Presley mais comment
expliquer ces 270 000 disques vendus la
réponse il faut la chercher chez ses
clients nouveaux que sont les moins de
18 ans qui ont leur mode bien à eux qui
imposent leur goûts et leurs vedettes
écoutez-la regardez-les vous comprendrez
les filles de mon promène dans la rue de
par deux
tous les garçons et les filles de mon
âge ça veut bien ce que c'est
4 requais les yeux dans les yeux et la
main dans la main il s'en vont amoureux
sans peur du lendemain oui mais moi
je vais seul par les rues
lamentais oui mais moi je vais seul car
personne ne m'aime
1113 cubains anti-castriste fait
prisonnier lors de la tentative de
débarquement de 1961 ont été rendus par
Fidel Castro ils ont retrouvé la liberté
à Miami et commencer l'année nouvelle en
famille après 20 mois de détention mais
rarement liberté aura été payé aussi
cher puisqu'il en a coûté aux États-Unis
sous forme de médicaments et aliments
divers une rançon de 47000 dollars par
prisonnier
on comprend que le président Kennedy est
tenu à venir saluer lui-même ses hommes
les prisonniers les plus chers de
l'histoire il tenait aussi à faire le
point devant les anti-castristes et
leurs amis de l'attitude américaine face
au régime cubain une attitude sans
concession ce que la première dame des
États-Unis s'est chargée de traduire en
espagnol
[Applaudissements]
les événements du Katanga sont un sujet
de préoccupation pour le monde entier
qui a vu avec stupeur les troupes des
Nations Unies écraser la résistance
katangaise avec une vigueur inattendue
69 gisait dans les décombres de
l'hôpital de l'Union Minière après les
violents combats qui opposaient à
Lubumbashi Ethiopien et catégorie
[Musique]
djembé comptait sur ses gendarmes et ses
troupes d'élite pour défendre pied à
pied le territoire qu'il contrôlait mais
tout son dispositif militaire semble
s'être soudainement effondré il ne lui
restait plus qu'à pratiquer la politique
de la terre brûlée et en détruisant tous
les ouvrages d'art essayer de retarder
l’avance des troupes de l'ONU avant
aussi rapide qu'elle semblait
embarrasser le secrétaire général de
l'ONU monsieur tante
[Musique]
les mercenaires européens qui
encadraient la gendarmerie kapenguez ont
été fait prisonniers
[Musique]
table des civils
sur les routes sur les pistes hommes
femmes et enfants s'acheminaient vers la
redésie voisine fuyant les horreurs de
la guerre
[Musique]
Hong Kong un port riche au frontières de
demande et tout autour des barraques
entassés des bidons vides trio une
capitale ultramodern avec des buildings
et une route qui dessine son tracé
futuriste sous un bidonville c'est un
phénomène général international New York
ou Moscou les bidonvilles n'épargnaient
aucune capitale Paris pas plus que les
autres et voici un document tourné en
toute objectivité malgré les difficultés
qu'on peut imaginer sur cette plaie des
grandes cités à Nanterre ou à La
Courneuve les bidons villes ressemblent
à ceux de toutes les latitudes il se
ressemblent tous quelques planches mal
jointes des toits fait de n'importe quoi
sur un terrain vague des hommes venus en
masse travailler dans la région
parisienne on fait naître ces cités
misérables africains du Nord portugais
espagnol et aussi des Français
si logite est précaire du moins il est
bon marché et dans ce souci d'économie
on peut trouver une des raisons d'être
du bidonville une seule fontaine pour
toute la triste agglomération c'est le
rendez-vous des enfants l'accord vedo
remplace souvent les codes
on vit entre soi des commerçants ont ici
leurs éventaires à la mesure et à
l'image de l'habitat
[Musique]
heure du marché ressemble à toutes les
heures de marché mais on est dans un
autre univers non l'univers de la misère
car la plupart de ces hommes ont un
emploi mais un univers de hasard de
passage insoupçonnable et souvent
insoupçonné
[Musique]
pas de service de nettoyage les chiens
s'en occupent
mais rien n'est redoutable comme l'hiver
lorsqu'ils cerne ses constructions
chances
il n'y a guère que le poil de fonte de
l'épicerie buvette qui prodigue quelques
chaleurs chaleur humaine aussi car c'est
là qu'on retrouve d'autres hommes
parlant la même langue à l'heure de la
détente
ailleurs il faut accumuler les vêtements
pour lutter contre ce froid que n'arrive
pas à combattre la flamme du foyer
ainsi vivent dans les conditions de la
misère des centaines de familles aux
portes de la grande ville
insouciant des enfants meubles se
décorent sans espoir de leur jeu sans
fin
[Musique]
comment résoudre le problème
continuellement méthodiquement les
constructions nouvelles grignotent les
bidonvilles
[Musique]
les bulldozers à date ici et là l'une de
ces cités de planches de parpaing et de
tôle pour laisser la place à des
habitations dignes de ce nom
seul va être un bidonville
la construction s'efforce de faire face
aux flux des nouveaux venus mais il ne
suffit pas de remplacer un bidonville
s'il doit en être un autre un peu plus
loin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
événement capital de la semaine 850
journalistes de la presse française et
internationale se trouvaient réunis à
l'Élysée pour la conférence de presse du
général de Gaulle qui a évoqué les
conditions de l'entrée de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché comme
alors il est possible
un jour
l'Angleterre
elle-même suffisamment
pour faire partie de la Communauté
européenne sans restriction sans réserve
les préférences à quoi que ce soit
et dans ce cas là les 6 ouvraient la
porte
répondante au président Kennedy et à son
offre de participation à une force
atomique multinationale le général de
Gaulle a rappel rappelait que la France
entend avoir un propre sa défense
nationale
et en particulier personne en Amérique
ne peut
dans quelle mesure
[Musique]
les armements nucléaires américains
seraient employé
à défendre l'Europe nous nous en tenons
à la décision que nous avons arrêté
construit et le cas échéant employé
nous-même
notre force atomique
- 8 au thermomètre à Paris les pigeons
qui ne trouvèrent plus une goutte d'eau
et les automobilistes auxquelles leur
moteur ont donné chaud en ont été les
premières victimes
[Musique]
la troisième vague de froid de cet hiver
a de nouveau gelé le lac du bois de
Boulogne où il a fallu casser la glace
pour les canards
sur le canal Saint-Martin les péniches
ont été immobileisés mais Paris n'a pas
eu le privilège des basses températures
toute la France ou presque a été logée à
la même enseigne
des spectacles de rêve mais des routes
difficilement praticables
des centaines de péniches bloquées sur
tous les canaux du Nord et de l'Est
Dunkerque aura pour sa part battu une
espèce de record sous un vin glacé le
thermomètre est descendu à moins 15 le
port de pêche a été totalement bloqué et
la mère devant Malo-les-Bains s'est
transformé en banquise la mère du Nord
gelée ce n'était pas jusqu'ici un
spectacle courant mais il risque de le
devenir puisque d'aucun promettent à
l'Europe des hivers aussi rigoureux
jusqu'en l'an 2000
[Musique]
malgré la vague de poids qui s'évite
actuellement aux États-Unis le sourire
de la Joconde a réchauffé le cœur des
Américains qui ont assisté le 8 janvier
dernier en présence du président et le
Madame Jacqueline Kennedy à la
présentation du chef-d'oeuvre de Léonard
de Vinci à la nationale Gallery de
Washington
présenté Marion André Malraux le
ministre français des Affaires
Culturelles la mortelle au regard divin
a conquis d'un sourire le président des
États-Unis
[Musique]
et là aussi conquis la foule américaine
qui était si nombreuse que chaque
visiteur n'a disposait que de quelques
secondes pour l'admirer
le Katanga Moïse chombay joue toujours
au chat et à la souris avec les Nations
Unies après s'être enfui une première
fois en Rhodésie du Sud le président
katangé faisant volte-face était décidé
à retourner dans sa capitale
Elisabethville le 10 janvier dernier
[Musique]
à peine arrivé dans son palais il était
mis quelques temps en résidence
surveillée il devait se faire acclamer
avant de disparaître à nouveau
[Musique]
certains ont vu avec soulagement l'homme
s'évadait d'une terre devenue trop
petite pour nourrir une humanité dont la
moitié est sous-alimentée et que sera ce
quand la population 3 milliards
aujourd'hui ce sera encore accru
c'est oublier un peu vite que les
nourritures terrestres sont loin d'être
toutes exploitées à leur rendement
maximum et c'est aussi faire peu
confiance au progrès des expériences
multiples ont déjà été tentées on est
allé jusqu'à explorer les effets de la
musique sur la croissance des plantes
méthode préconisée par certains savants
de l'Inde
[Musique]
manquerons un jour de terre arabe les
expériences de Gif-sur-Yvette ont montré
qu'on pouvait d'obtenir des rendements
saisissants en salaire sans perdre du
tout
quant aux pommes de terre excellentes le
rire radiation dans une pile atomique
peut nous les conserver des années sans
altération
passons sur les initiatives de bricolage
sur commande est aujourd'hui dépassée
par la production des poussins à
l'échelle véritablement industriels
[Musique]
quant au docteur Bombard il a démontré
les ressources considérables du plancton
marin se méconnu
et voici que le pétrole nous promet bien
davantage les cargaisons des tanker
moderne pourraient à elle seule nourrir
des régions entières après un certain
traitement toutefois cette espèce de
miracle dont on n'a pas fini de parler
ces produits dans cette raffinerie de
l'aveyra
dans des ballons sans cesse s'agiter et
aéré à 32 degrés une pincée de bactéries
mélangées à du pétrole le transforme en
protéines autrement dit on biftech ni
plus ni moins un bifteck qui aurait
l'apparence soit d'un liquide couleur de
café soit d'une poudre jaunâtre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un bifteck qui aurait un goût de fromage
aigre ou de levure mais parfaitement
nourrissant comme le vrai
adieu Amar à l'armoricaine adieu foie
gras à l'heure de midi le retérien de
demain n'aura plus qu'à vider son
éprouvette en 10 secondes on sent
combien le rendement il gagnera
[Musique]
on se protéger du froid le stade du
manoir à Colombes avait empilé un
immense manteau de paille en attendant
le premier match du Tournoi des cinq
nations 1963 opposant la France et
l'Écosse par moins 5 degrés les deux
équipes les Français en blanc sont tout
de suite dans le vif du sujet et au
départ on ne donne pas cher des chances
de la France face aux Écossais puissant
rapide et bien organisés il semble
pourtant qu'on se soit trompé adossé au
vent les Français font au moins Dieu
égal avec leurs adversaires dès qu'une
attaque des maillots blancs elle repart
presque immédiatement
il fait froid dans les tribunes mais pas
sur le terrain du moins pour le moment
et l'équipe de France encore plein de
dynamisme attaque avec chaleur et musel
les écossais qui n'en croit pas leurs
yeux et c'est ainsi que ce produit le
premier miracle du match le drop d'André
bonitas trois points pour la France
cela ne paraît pas tellement injuste
cependant les boules d'ozeurs écossais
attendent leurre ils ont le vent contre
eux ils le savent ils ne veulent pas
gâcher leur force avant la seconde
mi-temps
ils sont sans inquiétude même lorsque
Pierre elle baladait trois points de
plus sur coup franc à l'active des
Français
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
messieurs les Français quand nous aurons
le vent dans le dos à notre tour disent
les Écossais le fait dès le début de la
deuxième mi-temps ont pris sonne dans
l'équipe de France d'abord parce qu'on a
froid il fait maintenant moins 7 degrés
ensuite parce que les Écossais sont
mettre du terrain les cosmart 3 points
sur coup franc c'est le commencement de
la fin malgré quelques belles réactions
de la troisième ligne française
et avant de réussir fort justement à
laisser transformer à l'ultime minute du
match l'Ecosse avait entre temps marqué
trois autres points résultat 11 à 6 pour
les écossais
je suis français cette saison prend un
départ sur les chapeaux de roue c'est
d'abord le triomphe des bébés skieuses à
Grindelwald Marielle boitier lancette la
petite française ne connaît qu'une chose
lorsqu'elle est sur ses skis elle pense
comme un garçon dont elle a le ski et
l'efficacité et quand elle le désire
vraiment aucune de ses concurrentes lui
résiste pas même la championne du monde
l'Autrichienne Marianne et Marielle
Goitschel gagne ainsi le premier grand
salon de la saison
pour Émile Biola la descente du loverat
on a Wengen en Suisse alémanique c'est
exactement la répétition des
championnats du monde de l'an dernier à
Chamonix Viola est un fonceur il prend
des risques pour essayer de vaincre
l'invattable autrichien car le train
comme un Chamonix va le terminer second
et il aurait peut-être pu gagner s'il
n'avait pas cherché à forcer un peu trop
le destin
dans cette descente du lobar hand a
beaucoup fait penser à son compatriote
Tony salaire comme Tony seller il y a
quelques années je rentre sa surclasser
tous ses adversaires il est précis
efficace souple et puissant il y a des
jambes d'acier à l'arrivée il a plus de
4 secondes d'avance sur Viola
[Musique]
mais l'événement le plus extraordinaire
du lobe orange c'est le retour à la
surface de celui que l'on attendait plus
Guy Perry il y a deux ans il était le
meilleur skieur du monde depuis plus
rien ou presque sans rien dire cette
année presque confidentiellement il a
pris le départ du lover-house avec le
désir de gagner c'est maintenant chose
faite une victoire sans discussion dans
le slalom et la première place du
combiné
[Musique]
50000 personnes attend frisquet mais du
soleil à gogo pour la plus grande
épreuve européenne de l'année au 3 atlé
le Prix d'Amérique à Vincennes comme les
gens heureux les grandes courses
hippiques sont presque toujours sans
histoire aux eaux la jument numéro 1 du
turf français n'a pas déçu les parieurs
dès le départ menait un bon battant elle
a pris la tête pour tout le monde la
course était déjà terminée ozo est une
jument étonnante et la mauvais caractère
en cours celle ne décolle pas il paraît
qu'elle n'aime pas son driver entre les
lui c'est le mariage forcé elle obéit
donc mais elle se fâche et elle le
montre en giflant son driver d'une queue
vengeresse
[Musique]
tout cela n'empêche pas ce couple
insolite de remporter de nombreuses
victoires avec autant d'aisance que ce
Prix d'Amérique
Zoé sandriver ne s'arrêteront pas en si
bon chemin à moins que tout cela ne
finisse par un divorce
cette année au rallye de Monte-Carlo
c'est avec la panoplie du parfaite homme
des neiges à bord de sa voiture que
chacun des concurrents a pris le départ
rien n'a été épargné au pilote tempête
de neige verglas route bloquée par des
congères de 2 mètres de haut ainsi tous
les concurrents venant d'Athènes sont
restés en route quelque part en
Yougoslavie ils ont dû prendre l'avion
pour arriver à Monaco c'est un comble
sur les 296 voitures au départ des 7
itinéraires 102 seulement pu rejoindre
la Principauté tant bien que mal puisque
27 seulement d’entre elles sont arrivés
dans les délais
après temps des preuves le soleil de
Monaco a fait risette à ceux qui ont eu
la chance de terminer c'est un
récidiviste le géant suédois Carlson sur
une voiture suédoise également une
petite Saab 5 chevaux qui a remporté le
32e rallye de Monte-Carlo il avait en
effet déjà gagné l'an dernier
[Musique]
le prince Régnié la princesse Grèce ont
vivement féliciter les rescapés de ce
rallye qui espèrent encore faire mieux
la prochaine fois
[Musique]
n'est-ce pas monsieur Carlson jamais
deux sans trois
[Musique]
ce docile mastodonte c'est le dernier
cri des engins de transport des forces
du Pacte atlantique malgré son poids et
son volume il se promène allègrement
tout terrain avec l'agilité d'une
chenille il est vrai que chacune de ces
roues est complètement indépendante des
autres
c'est le monsieur passe partout les
armées alliées il n'hésite même pas à se
mouiller quand c'est nécessaire
il ne lui manque plus que des ailes pour
voler
mais patience le camion roulant
naviguant et volant c'est sans doute
pour demain
à Dublin le match France - Irlande de
rugby a bien mal commencé pour les
Français qui encaissent un essai
transformé signé Aurélie après 20
minutes de jeu 5-0 on se rappelle à ce
moment la défaite de la France devant
l'école
et puis sur mets les ouvertes la balle
fuse vers les trois quarts français Guy
Boniface profite de l'aubaine
la situation est complètement renversée
quelques minutes plus tard sur un drop
de Pierre alberté donc à la mi-temps six
à 5 pour la France c'est un peu trop
flatteur il faut l'avouer
[Musique]
les Français prennent la chance du bout
des doigts passe croisé d'Al balade des
jours à André Boniface drop trois points
de plus
[Musique]
à peine remis de leur surprise les
Irlandais vont encaisser un nouvel essai
de débordement que marque imparablement
darrouilles entre les poteaux tout cela
est bien conçu mais l'équipe d'Irlande
n'est pas dans un bon jour les Français
ont réellement une réussite incroyable
dans les 22 mètres irlandais encore une
fois la balle repart tous les trois
quarts Français sont en attaque daroui
marque son troisième essai de la journée
24 à 5 pour la France mais c'est trop
beau pour être vrai attendons la
confirmation devant les Anglais
à Paris dans le salon Murat de l'Élysée
au cours d'une séance solennelle le
général de Gaulle et le chancelier à
denauer en présence des principaux
ministres français et allemands ont
signé le texte du traité qui associe
désormais France et Allemagne sur le
plan de la politique étrangère de la
défense de l'Information et de la
Culture le président français et le
chancelier allemand se sont déclarés
convaincus que cet événement historique
est une étape essentielle sur la voie de
l'Europe unie car illustre d'une manière
éclatante l'esprit de coopération entre
les deux pays
depuis bientôt un mois et demi le monde
entier à froid recroquevillé sous la
neige la ville de Varsovie s'est
transformée en désert polaire ou
s'aventure parfois quelques passantes et
mes raies
dans le port les bateaux eux aussi
s'endorment dans leur cocon de glace
par tout ailleurs en Europe fleuve et
canaux se sont changés en long ruban
givrée sur lesquels sont immobilisés
bateau et remorqueurs cette paralysie
des voies de communication et
catastrophique le charbon reste sur les
quais alors qu'il se fait de plus en
plus rare dans les habitations
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en Californie on n'avait pas vu cela
depuis 50 ans moins 17 dans la vallée de
sanihakim réputé pour son éternel
printemps pour sauver les oranges
frigorifiées par le gel des brasero ont
été allumés bien inutilement d'ailleurs
la plupart des arbres étaient déjà morts
et cet hiver n'en finit pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un coup de baguette magique celle d'un
grand financier et megève est devenu
subitement la station de ski la plus
luxueuse du monde une station que
contemple accrochait dans la neige un
portrait géant de Jacqueline Kennedy
tracé par son admirateur numéro 1 le
peintre René casassus
[Musique]
le clou de ce Megève New Look pour
milliardaire en vacances c'est l'hôtel
du monde Arbois
[Musique]
qui cultive le superflu beaucoup plus
encore que le nécessaire et on aime
également l'insolite dans le nouveau
paradis du ski après
[Musique]
et quel panorama
pour un skieur blasé
après le calme de la piscine dans la
neige à la mairie de Megève sedouragan
on se croirait au métro Concorde à 6
heures du soir et tout cela pour
l'événement historique de l'année Sacha
Distel abandonne ses copains il épouse
Francine Bréau en toute intimité 150
photographes et des admirateurs comme
s'il en pleuvait
[Musique]
depuis que la battu à plate couture
toutes les vedettes féminines du ski
international à Saint-Gervais anifamoz
le nouveau bébé champion français et
désormais elle aussi la proie des
photographes
[Musique]
honoré Bonnel entraîneur de l'équipe de
France est moins heureux avec ses
garçons qui n'ont pas tellement brillé
dans la coupe Émile allait dans la
descente en tout cas Viola et peria sont
bien songeur avant l'épreuve
perrien le voici en pleine course dans
le mur de bornée c'est là que va se
jouer la victoire de l'Autrichien
Zimmermann vous allez voir comme
maintenant toujours au même endroit
c'est mieux que peyria qui livre va
terminer ce goût Zimmermann le voilà
clé comme une flèche dès le départ
[Musique]
ici ils fonce à 120 à l'heure sur une
neige dure comme du bois chaque bosse
chaque secousses est un supplice pour
les gens
[Musique]
il arrive au mur de bornée c'est là
qu'il va gagner ces quatre secondes
d'avance sur Jean-Claude Killy et ses 10
secondes sur péria
un bon de 15 m
[Musique]
Zimmerman et cette année le meilleur
descendeur du monde
[Musique]
il fonce jusqu'à la dernière seconde
résultat 80 de moyenne horaire record de
peria archibatus perria qui en pleurait
de dépistes et consoles et de ses
déboires en descente en remportant le
slalom il reçoit les félicitations de
ses amis Roger Vadim et Sacha Distel et
Madame Sacha Distel y joint un baiser
sur l'ajout de son ancien camarade de
l'équipe de France
[Musique]